let's start with
uh kimberly what is it like returning
to this role especially with the sequels
wrinkle of
having a touch of a fraught relationship
with your daughter with the addition of
a potential
new stepfather yeah i was
really excited to come back and play
claire again in this sort of
second chapter of their lives and when
we met them
last time claire was very raw and really
missing her husband
and just not knowing how she was going
to pull the family together to get
through it
and then now in the sequel she's she's
had some time to recover
and she's fallen in love and not
everybody in the family is on board with
it so now she's stuck
between wanting to grow and move forward
and create a new blended family
and trying to protect the feelings of
her daughter
but i was really excited to play the
role again yeah that's great um
for you darby uh what is it like
learning this mythological made-up
language of elvish what is the what is
the process of learning and speaking
that
um it was it was very interesting i
never
uh done anything like that before for a
film where i had to learn the
i mean it's a fake language but uh the
words actually do mean something like
someone wrote it which was very neat um
but it was really hard to learn it
because it's a very
spec it's very specific each word and
um it was very hard but i thought it was
very cool i never done anything like
that before
it was a really cool experience yeah did
you have anyone on set to kind of remind
you what words meant what
or uh yes actually i would have to
listen to like recordings uh whenever i
could
and try to get the right sound and um
and
they would tell me what it means so i
could like say it right
um but yeah i had to like listen to
recordings to get that
that perfect sound you know yeah
it was very convincing um a question for
both of you we'll start with kimberly
i really love the device in the film
that can turn
one's least favorite food into one's
favorite food
uh i'm curious kimberly what would be
your choice what would be the food
the worst food that you would turn into
the best food
yeah what a great question i think i
would turn
corned beef hash into
ice cream what flavor ice cream
oh definitely like a chocolate toffee
something like that
oh i love a toffee that's great how
about you darby
um i would probably turn like celery
i hate celery i'm sorry i was like put
it into
like a really good taste and like drink
like a
like a um like a soda or something but
not necessarily a saying like a slushy
you know like to like a um sour apple
slushie or something that sounds really
good